[Applause]
Ali and Sasha
[Applause]
is this the new team name the why the
sad face you don't know exactly well I
got to tell you guys first of all we're
gonna stay positive then let's talk
about how Kerry Ann told you you had the
best freestyle she'd ever seen in the
history of the show I gotta tell you we
were shocked then we were shocked to not
see you at least in the top two and and
I have to know what was going through
your mind standing up there and all that
intensity I mean it it was scary
we've been there before so we know what
it feels like and I to be honest my main
goal was for her to shine tonight no
matter what happens no matter who went
through losers and before we started
this dance I was I told her I was like I
love this whole performance and the
performance was all about her it was all
about her it was all she came out she
delivered I've never seen her dance at
the way she did like when that ball
opened and she came out I was like okay
I know now I know I'm sorry now I know
I'm happy no matter what happens well
what was your reaction to hannah winning
what we've read about my god they were
both incredible and she she's incredible
she turned into an incredible dancer
congratulations and the thing is
everybody was amazing like it's not like
there's one person who you like oh that
person is for sure gonna win everybody
was amazing so it was like anybody's
game and I'm so happy for Hannah she is
so happy and excited and I love Alan too
he has been such a sweetheart to me the
whole season so we're happy for them and
we're gonna freakin celebrate when we
get on that jet to New York y'all we're
gonna Jay you look you've been on the
show a while would you is this keep
going keep going
toughest final there's ever been
um definitely hands down definitely my
favorite Pinal ever like I said I feel
like it's it's so hard to create every
week and especially for 11 weeks and
it's just been so rewarding creating
dances for her and I knew like I wanted
this freestyle to feel like no one
else's and it just came together like
like a puzzle and that's because of this
one it was so fun watching you all
season you're amazing you're amazing
thank you
[Music]